hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar optimizing
antimicrobial stewardship by combining
multiplex PCR and biomarker results in
patients with sepsis I'm Suzy Valdez of
lab routes and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you today by
Bill Miro a world leader in the field of
in vitro diagnostics for over 55 years
biomerieux is present in 43 countries
and serves more than 160 countries with
a support of a large network of
distributors bill muriel provides
diagnostic solutions systems reagents
software and services which determine
the source of disease and contamination
to improve patient health and ensure
consumer safety its products are mainly
used for diagnosing infectious diseases
and some critical illnesses the
company's diagnostic solutions are also
used for detecting micro organisms in a
dry food pharmaceutical and cosmetic
products to learn more about them visit
them at WWF IOM Rieu x.com let's get
started you can pose questions to the
speaker today during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled asked a question and
click the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience any tip technical problems
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen this edge
educational webinar and says offers free
continuing education credits simply
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
without further ado I now present
today's speaker dr. John Rowe Rico
dr. burr Rico is the co-director of the
antimicrobial stewardess program at the
clinical infectious diseases pharmacist
at Duke Regional Hospital in Durham
North Carolina dr. burr Rico is a
co-director of the antimicrobial
stewardship program and the clinical
infectious disease pharmacist at the
hospital and he received a doctorate of
pharmacy at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill at the
board-certified infectious disease
pharmacists dr. borracho has been
utilizing biomarkers and diagnostics for
more than 10 years and spearheaded the
implementation and education at his
hospital dr. Brickell will now begin his
presentation welcome sir Thank You
Sussie for that nice introduction
and thank you to be a mere you who is a
large supporter of all antibiotic
stewardship programs around the world my
disclosure obviously be Amir you is
sponsoring this presentation so the
objectives for today we're going to
examine how biomarkers and multiplex PCR
assist in the diagnosis of sepsis we're
also going to examine how these results
can benefit patient care when used in
conjunction with an antibiotic
stewardship program so let's start off
with the patient case we have a 62 year
old male who was admitted from his
skilled nursing facility with coughing
hypoxia past medical history is
consistent for coronary artery disease
status post a cabbage is a fifth which
is controlled by warfarin he has an
aortic valve replacement and pneumonia
seven months prior to admission his
vital signs with temperature is thirty
six seven heart rate 78 respirations 20
a and a blood pressure of 89 over 55 his
labs are notable for a white count of
16.8 platelets of 130 and his INR is
currently 3.4 his goal in the home
setting or his skilled facility is two
to three biomarkers procalcitonin is 40
point two eight his previous values
seven to twelve months ago were negative
at less than 0.01 nanograms per mil he's
posted for ICU admission with septic
shock
antibiotics are initiated in the
emergency room vancomycin and pip Tazo
microbiology urinary antigens are normal
his urine was mixed his blood showed two
out of two Pseudomonas species via the
bio fire film array system
patient outcome we will examine in a few
slides so let's look at the burden of
antibiotic use in the hospital setting
slide that just about everybody uses in
every presentation whether it be on
sepsis mortality or antibiotic
stewardship the CDC estimates that each
year in this country two million people
in the u.s. choir and infection while
hospitalized resulting in ninety
thousand deaths and approximately 20 to
50 percent of antibiotics prescribed in
u.s. acute care hospitals are
unnecessary or inappropriate
when we look at the epidemiology of
sepsis encrypt care medicine drum browse
key and colleagues estimated that from
1993 to 2003 the severe sepsis cases
increased continuously from about 25
percent almost 44 percent and that for
that same time period the age adjusted
rates for severe sepsis hospitalizations
and mortality increased annually by
eight point two percent for
hospitalizations and 5.6 percent for
mortality and then Martin in the New
England Journal of Medicine estimates
that greater than 750,000 cases of
sepsis occur annually in the United
States it accounts for 11% of all ICU
admissions
looking at mortality of sepsis sepsis
contributes to one in every two to three
Hospital deaths with most sepsis already
present upon admission and most common
cause of death in the non coronary
I see use of all the sources of
infection the respiratory tract is the
most common and associated with the
highest mortality rate and after onset
of septic shock mortality increases for
every hour of delayed treatment by seven
point six percent per hour
this was an excellent study by Seymour
in the New England Journal of Medicine
they wanted to look at the time to
treatment and mortality during an
emergency room care for sepsis so what
they did was they examine patients with
presumed sepsis and or septic shock
between April of 2014 and June of 2016
other outcome was to assess the
association between the time and full
completion of a three-hour bundle and
risk adjusted mortality they also
examine the time to the appropriate
administration of the antibiotics and
the initial fluid bolus they pretty
robust they looked at over 49,000
patients and I guess thankfully eighty
two point five percent of the patients
completed their three-hour bundle within
three hours the meeting time to
completion of the three-hour bundle was
1.3 hours antibiotic administration 0.9
hours and the initial fluid bolus two
point five six hours
so as far as results the sepsis bundle
completed within three or after three
hours but less than 12 hours had a
statistically significant increased risk
adjusted and Hospital mortality
mortality the odds ratio 1.0 for the
longer time to get antibiotics also a
risk or odds ratio of 1.0 for and less
so for fluid boluses with an odds ratio
of 1.0 one
so their conclusion a more rapid
completion of a tree our bundle of
sepsis care and rapid administration of
antibiotics but not the rapid completion
of an initial bolus of IV fluids were
associated with lower risk adjusted in
hospital mortality
also results again this forest plot
looks at in hospital death less likely
to the left of the line and more likely
to the right of the line and you can see
that overwhelmingly that in hospital
death was more likely with the adjusted
odds ratio for not meeting that tree our
sepsis bundle
this is just a graphic form of the same
information in hospital mortality and
then time to completion so you can see
when you complete it within three hours
you have a much less both risk-adjusted
and crude mortality rate
same thing with administration of
antibiotics within three hours crude
mortality and risk adjusted mortality
statistically less significant and
there's the fluid bolus which shows that
if you don't meet that three hour bundle
there was really no change and either
crude mortality or risk adjusted
mortality
so let's look at procalcitonin it's
produced in the C cells of the thyroid
gland bacterial infections basically
stimulate from Casselton and production
of the eye interleukins TNF alphas with
a non bacterial infection a virus will
secrete gamma interferon which actually
inhibits the production of procalcitonin
we know concentrations greater than 0.25
milligrams can indicate significant
bacterial infections and studies have
shown that levels greater than 2
nanograms per mil indicated high risk of
severe sepsis or septic shock
Latonia when you compare it with other
biomarkers we know that tnf-alpha and
interleukin 6 and 10 peak almost
immediately but then decrease and that
would be responsible for a patient who
might come to the emergency room a
little later after the initial bacterial
infection CRP is the dark green line and
that usually takes about six hours to
begin peeking but then stays elevated
the issue with CRP is that it does not
differentiate between bacterial and
viral infections and just is indicative
of inflammation within the one
procalcitonin starts the peak or starts
it to set about two hours and will
continue peeking until appropriate
antibiotics are administered and then
stays until about 24 hours and then with
the task life of 24 hours we'll can
start its decline
now why is this important well we
already know that we're trying to attain
the three our sepsis bundle so if we
were just going to rely on CRP we may
not have started the peak yet and be
unaware that the patient may or may not
be going into sepsis but a quicker
biomarker like procalcitonin may give
you a slight edge as far as identifying
that patient who is heading towards
sepsis
understanding procalcitonin kinetics
usually rises again between three and
six hours after the initial infection
obviously it's patient independent so
it's going to be different in each
patient as they come through your
emergency room normally Peaks between 12
and 24 hours and with the half-life of
24 hours you would expect with
appropriate antibiotics that you would
have about a 50% decrease in the
procalcitonin value this is important
for stewardship programs we know that if
fund a to your procalcitonin has not
decreased by about 50% that or it has
gone up you'll need to examine whether
or not your antibiotic regimen is
appropriate or if there's another source
of infection that you haven't identified
but if inta biotics are adequate you
should expect that 50% decline in the
procalcitonin from the baseline that was
obtained in the emergency room
you
shoots that an excellent Cochrane
systematic review back in 2012 and his
primary outcome was all caused mortality
and treatment failure at 30 days the
secondary outcomes antibiotic use and
about related adverse effects and length
of today
and here's the results he would bid over
6,700 patients and between the
procalcitonin group and the control
group mortality was slightly less but
not statistically significant for the
procow group treatment failure was not
statistically different and in subgroup
analysis they found no difference but
antibiotic use and adverse effects were
statistically significantly less when
you follow the procalcitonin guided
antibiotic logarithm and length of stay
and ICU stayed there was no difference
between the two groups
so his conclusions when you use a
procalcitonin guided therapy versus a
controlled group you have lower risk of
mortality lower antibiotic consumption
and a lower risk for antibiotic related
side-effects the good thing about this
Cochrane review was that our results
were similar for different clinical
settings so this was both outpatient
clinics emergency rooms medical floors
and intensive care units in all types of
acute respiratory infections so he
looked at all forms of lower respiratory
and upper respiratory tract infections
you
so how do we use procalcitonin in an
antibiotic stewardship team in our
hospital we use it in the emergency room
as a test of exclusion in patients with
presumed LRT is that's not where this
conversation is going this afternoon but
that is one of the reasons that we use
it we do use it to again hopefully not
initiate antibiotics or stop antibiotics
after just one dose in anybody with an
exacerbation of asthma bronchitis COPD
and congestive heart failure
interestingly enough the recent cap
guidelines recommended not using
procalcitonin and community-acquired
pneumonia basically if you had clinical
suspicion that your patient did have an
infectious cap that not to use
procalcitonin to exclude using
antibiotics that is absolutely correct
but worded strangely you can still use
procalcitonin but you would never use
that negative procalcitonin in the
presence of in the presence of cap side
effects and not initiate antibiotics so
how we're going to use it today in the
emergency room we'll use it as a
baseline value in patients with presumed
sepsis so in our ICU or our internal
medicine patients we will use it as a
guide to de-escalate antibiotics and
culture-negative patients so again we'll
get our baseline in the emergency room
we'll identify that they potentially are
heading toward sepsis which means we
could initiate the 3-hour sepsis bundle
sooner on day two if that procalcitonin
is 50 percent or less from day one we
know that we're going in the right
direction and on day three at that
procalcitonin is 80 percent of day one
and your patient is culturally negative
and we know that we can deescalate in
about
well there are some limitations to
procalcitonin the absolute limitations
are people with end-stage renal disease
renal cell carcinoma thyroid cancers and
severe burns and trauma
there are some relative limitations in
our hospital we did a one-year study and
found that patients with CKD 3 and CKD 4
also had similarly falsely elevated
procalcitonin not small cell lung cancer
with or without lobectomy is also a
relative limitation Aki
very difficult to quantify we don't know
if the Aki is using the bank dose in
combination if it's coming from
untreated sepsis so it's really
difficult to superimpose the timeline
when procalcitonin is going to increase
but yet it's falsely increased because
of the Aki so that's a opportunity for
further studies down the road
so this is except this algorithm for
procalcitonin antibiotic use and the
first thing you'll notice is that it's
basically all the values are twice as
high as for L RTI sepsis algorithm so if
you're less than 0.25 nanograms per mil
that we know that cessation is strongly
encouraged or if you're between two
point 0.25 and 0.49 that cessation is
encouraged once you're above 0.5 then
cessation is discouraged or strongly
discouraged based on the number
to option the BMC notes he looked at
procalcitonin to predict mortality and
patients with sepsis and his line of
demarcation was seven nanograms per ml
so the green line would represent
procalcitonin less than seven and of
course his survival was greater than
those who had a procalcitonin greater
than seven nanograms per mil this is
just a box plot to show the same thing
the lower your procalcitonin the greater
your survivor is and we've seen this in
our hospital time and time again we know
that once your procalcitonin is greater
than two nanograms per mil that sepsis
is likely and the higher you go the
greater the microbial burden and the
higher your mortality rate potentially
will be
you
so this is our other biomarker we're
using it's a faster actionable or FA the
bio fire it's a blood culture or
identification or the BC ID panel we
know when we look at traditional blood
cultures we need to wait for the blood
culture to turn positive which depending
on the organism is anywhere between 12
and 72 hours when you use standard
testing pathogen identification usually
within 24 to 72 hours and then you still
have to await any microbial
susceptibility testing but with the BC
ID panel and Gram stain we know that we
could decrease the time compared to
traditional modes by 70% and that's
fifty seven point four hours for the
standard 17 point two hours for the BC
ID method and I'm going to show you some
data from our Hospital towards the end
of the presentation that pretty much
matches those numbers
you
so is bc ID effective is it sensitive is
it specific that's something that's very
important for stewardship teams that's
nice to bring in a test but if it's not
going to give you actionable data that
we could actually bring upstairs to the
patient we need to work on that so this
was a great study by Pargo and
diagnostic microbial infectious disease
he wanted to look at the clinical and
economic impact of antibiotic
stewardship interventions using the BCI
D panel of course this was a pre and a
post cohort so corporal comparison
evaluated the effect of BC ID
implementation versus standard of care
without a BC ID and he mainly looked at
Co AG negative staph and miss up for his
result BC ID results facilitated earlier
discontinuation of Benko when G PCs and
clusters were identified as either ko AK
or miss up so the left side of that
table is just for Missa alone and you
know understandably that that number is
pretty well it's only 32 patients but
it's ELISA snapshot to help us out so of
course the control group would be
without BC ID and the BC ID would be
with it the good news is that out of all
the patients a hundred percent started
vancomycin for GP sees and clusters but
remarkably only half of the patients in
the BC ID group got more than one dose
whereas a considerable amount got or did
not get just one dose and when you look
at the median duration of antibiotic use
in the control group of 66 hours
the BC ID group was 14 hours and those
last two items were statistically
significant when you go over to the Co
AG negative staff side again a fair
amount of patients received vancomycin
I guess kudos to the stewardship and the
physician teams for those hospitals
because that means they understand
that would rapid Diagnostics that they
don't have to jump on a lab saying that
hey we got one out of two G pcs and
clusters and they didn't start making
mice and so hopefully we can bring that
72 in that 70 down a little bit farther
and of course one dose only was just
about the same and not statistically
significant and the median duration of
antibiotic therapy although it was
statistically less than the BCI D group
it was not statistically significant
because of a lack of power
so when we look at procalcitonin when we
look at three pluses that means that the
calcitonin is most likely to be positive
and we know it's definitely for
pneumonia both upper and lower
respiratory tract we know for meningitis
that procalcitonin is expected to be
quite high and severe sepsis and septic
shock procalcitonin will be inordinately
high as far as you know still positive
it would be the LRT eyes so your
bronchitis COPD pulmonary fibrosis and
asthma congestive heart failure is on
there but the caveat only severe
congestive heart failure will cause
procalcitonin to rise so if your patient
has chronically stable CHF you would
expect a negative procalcitonin which
might allow you to discontinue
antibiotics since the shortness of
breath is probably secondary to fluid
overload and procalcitonin is definitely
positive and abdominal infections and
pancreatitis and in our Hospital we're
noticing that it's also positive with
cfdisk infections they with urinary
tract infections is positive but in our
Hospital that's only true if you have a
concomitant vector emia or if it's a
pyelonephritis where you have more
tissue involvement and urine
so let's go back to our patient if we
had used standard micro detection from
the time of the blood collection to the
Gram stain result depending on again the
organism anywhere from eighteen and
thirty hours from the time of the grand
stain result to the pathogen ID another
six to twenty four hours and from the
time of the pathogen ID to a sensitivity
report twelve to twenty-four hours
but fortunately our hospital uses the B
CI D piano so from the time of blood
collection to vancomycin discontinuation
twenty-six hours from the time of the
Gram stain results the pathogen ID was
only eight point five hours and from the
time of the pathogen ID with
sensitivities to narrowing of therapy
two hours
so final look at our patient on day
three he was on day three of appropriate
therapy with pip Tazo he was clinically
stable with return to baseline all vital
signs and laboratory parameters were
within normal limits he was posted for
discharge to continue oral antibiotic
therapy to complete a seven-day course
the importance and applicability of
using fast and actionable diagnostics
and hospitalized patients at ID week
this past October in Washington there
was a great quote that I cannot take
credit for but the clinician basically
said if a rapid diagnostic result falls
in the forest basically a metaphor for
if nobody looks at the result if it's
not actionable if it's not paired with
the robust antibiotic stewardship then
rapid Diagnostics lose some of their
sensitivities so we know from our
previous conversations that using rapid
Diagnostics
we can decrease resistance we can
decrease adverse events associated with
antimicrobials we can decrease cost
hospital pharmacy department and
hopefully improve patient outcomes
so let's we'll get antibiotic resistance
this is a chart with the four clone
resistance for Pseudomonas and you can
see unfortunately that blue line is a
direct increase from overuse of
quinolones from feeding cows and
chickens antibiotics which include
quinolones which gives us drug-resistant
mutations that are in our stomachs so
just overuse of quinolones is causing
most quinolones especially ciprofloxacin
to be basically ineffective in most
infections in this country
same thing that CDC and who they've
listed the various organisms as either
urgent critical serious for CRE that's
both urgent and critical with an
estimated death 600 per year
Acinetobacter is also serious and
critical with up to 500 deaths per year
ESBL which were seeing a lot of in our
hospital these days that serious and
critical I would say that in our
Hospital I now consider it urgent and
critical with as much as 1,700 deaths
VRE serious and high Pseudomonas is
serious and critical MRSA is serious and
high and buchanan's all resistant
Candida is also serious and who did not
acknowledge that particular bugs of
nothing on that table
so our first point was we can decrease
antibiotic associated adverse events so
this is a great study by Tama in JAMA
internal medicine in 2017 it was a
cohort study which examined fourteen
hundred and eighty-eight patients for 30
days after initiation of the antibiotic
therapy and they found that 20%
experienced at least one antibiotic
associated a de twenty percent of non
clinically indicated antibiotic
regiments were associated with the ad e
including C difficile infection and for
every additional ten days of therapy
there was a three percent risk of an ad
E and not uncommon the most common
adverse drug events were
gastrointestinal renal and hematological
and when you look at emergency room
visits antibiotics are still in the top
four four reasons for presentation they
are right up there with opioids and
anti-diabetic agents so these are not
benign substances
critical care medicine also looked at
adverse effects this was a systematic
review and meta-analysis he was
assessing acute kidney injury with
combination therapy of Bank pip Tazo in
adults and in critically ill patients so
his primary outcome was examined the
rates of day ki in the time to a ki and
he looked at the odds of a ki and he
compared three different cohorts
vancomycin mono therapy a bank plus
cefepime and or carbapenem and then pip
Tazo mono therapy
and when you look at the four cohorts
you can see that overwhelmingly Bank
tipped azo combination at the greatest
percentage with a ki so we've known that
for several years now that that
combination does increase a ki and at
our Hospital at least we're starting to
go more and more with the bank cefepime
metronidazole combination which has been
known to decrease Aki incidents
this is just a forest plot this is Bank
pip Tazo versus Bank
cefepime and they're measuring how soon
to Aki and as you can see it
overwhelmingly favors in a not so
favorable moment of Bank pip Tazo is
causing quicker Aki and your patience
you
this is also a bank by itself versus
bank pip Tazo and again the forest plot
shows you that the bank kept a zone
combination causes a ki more than just
vancomycin mono therapy when you look at
the bank cefepime or bank Mero versus
Bank baptizo again thank a kaizo
combination causes more a ki
and lastly when looking at mono therapy
with pip Tazo versus Bank kaizo
combinations again we know who wins in
this one
and these are the adverse events the
comparator versus the Bank potato and
any of the other three computers have
better kidney profiles than the
combination of Bank and pip Tazo
as far as decreased cost let's just do
the math right if we prescribe fewer
antibiotics if we consume less
antibiotics
that's fewer antibiotics that our
purchaser has to write a check out for
so you know it's proof positive that
when we're using less antibiotics that
it's a win-win situation for the
hospital and the hospital pharmacy
department now what we need to do is
convince all the executives out there
that the micro lab also results in
significantly decreased costs we're just
always hearing that the micro lab is too
expensive you know that all these fast
Diagnostics are prohibitively expensive
than we need to educate and change how
we do in rewrite computer programs but
bottom line is with fast Diagnostics the
micro lab saves hospitals hundreds of
thousands of dollars per year
you
all right what about reduce reduce
antibiotic exposure and mortality this
was a great study in Lancet infectious
disease in 2016
again two cohorts were the procalcitonin
guided antibiotic regimens versus
standard of care antibiotic regimens and
you can see antibiotic consumption in
days of daily defying doses in the first
28 days were statistically in favor of
procalcitonin duration of antibiotic
therapy were also statistically in favor
of procalcitonin and the antibiotic free
days in the first 28 days also favored
procalcitonin when you will get
mortality and when you look at one-year
mortality there was no statistical
significance but when we're using fast
Diagnostics to de-escalate antibiotics
if we can maintain the same mortality
both that 28 days and 1 year or whatever
time period you want to look at that's a
winning situation because you would
normally expect intuitively that no I'm
using less antibiotics I would expect
some deleterious effects where my
patient may be at increased risk of
mortality but I haven't seen a study
that has shown that yet
and this is another study
it's a procalcitonin guided antibiotic
therapy from other selected
meta-analyses and you can see that it's
over 20,000 patients and basically
looking at mortality and antibiotic
duration in all five of those analyses
of antibiotic duration will
statistically decreased and immortality
three out of the five studies showed a
decrease in mortality and two of the
studies no change in mortality
so we can outcomes continued this is a
snapshot study for our hospital it's
pending on IRB and our primary outcome
was time to narrow in a microbial
therapy
so the yeast of fast and actionable
where's my result sorry about that let's
go to the previous slide oh there we go
so our snapshot results our medium time
to narrow antimicrobial therapy was
eighteen point seven hours that's at
least one half of what one would expect
and in some instances it was as much as
one-third of what we would expect so you
know those results are just a good
outcomes for the hospital good outcomes
for the patient we are going away from
combination therapy and narrowing to
appropriate therapy in light speed we're
doing it within sometimes within 20
within 24 hours to get to the absolute
appropriate antibiotic which is really
just a great great thing for the patient
and you know again we really appreciate
all these fast diagnostics that are
coming through to help stewardship teams
and hospitals on our patients so what
are our take-home points we already know
that the use of fast and actionable
diagnostic has the ability to
significantly reduce time on
broad-spectrum antibiotics you know
we're going from 72 to 96 hours down to
17 to 30 hours we already know that it's
intuitively if we are stepping away from
broad-spectrum antibiotics that we have
the ability to decrease antibiotic
resistance we already know that the
lessee antibiotics you consume that
adverse events are less likely to occur
we already know that it saves money and
we already know that from a mortality
benefit it improves patient outcomes
with that I turn it over to the
moderator for any questions you might
have for me
thank you
dr. burrito for that presentation and a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and then just
click on the send button
dr. barranco will answer as many
questions as we have time today so let's
take a look at our first audience
questions coming in dr. brocco our first
one is do you have to confirm CR E
well it's you do need to confirm it our
micro lab right now runs CRE enzymes and
that's one of the more advantages of the
bio fire that you know right now the
only will get three resistance
mechanisms but they're going to
significantly expand that within the
next several months they also look at
just a certain number of gram positive
gram negatives and fungals but that's
also going to be expanded significantly
so we're actually going to get more
positive reads on different
antimicrobials but which also include
the resistance enzymes
thank you for that dr. burrito our next
question is what is a turnaround time
for PCT and the BC ID panel okay we put
our procalcitonin in the chemistry lab
because it was a 24/7 operation and it's
also used from the same blood tube as
the BMP so what happens is the tube goes
to our chemistry lab they do their BMP
and then they immediately send it over
to the procalcitonin machine if we run
it stat we get the results within one
hour if we run it routine we get it
within two hours so that is definitely
an actionable number that we can use in
our Hospital BC ID we need we still need
to wait for the blood culture to go
positive but then the identification is
within hours it's really pretty amazing
I know it's making my job as a steward
so much easier because you know now I
just have the evidence behind it to
rapidly deescalate antibiotics and then
further narrow after we get the
sensitivity pattern in the mi C's back
thank you and again thank you to our
audience members we have some great
questions coming in our next one is we
are noticing PCT rising for the first 24
hours on antibiotics and then dropping
can you address that well it depends
when the patient presents from the
initial bacterial insult
not all people are going or patients are
going to follow that timeline 24 hours
would be a bit much to wait for a peak
you know normally we see it peak
anywhere from two to eight hours about
ninety percent of our patients peak
between that time frame again whenever
it goes up we're a little concerned that
we don't have the right antibiotics but
you know with the 24 hour half-life
maybe for that particular patient it
just took longer for them to respond to
the antibiotics allowing the
procalcitonin to start its decline
thank you and here's the next question
how reliable is procalcitonin when
peeking within the first 24 to 48 hours
of presentation but after antibiotics
have been initiated we've had several
patients who we thought we had the right
antibiotic or we thought we had the
source of the infection but yet it just
the procalcitonin was not appropriately
declining so we just maybe enhanced our
antibiotics a little bit and maybe did
some more diagnostic scanning or imaging
or CT scanning to maybe identify another
source of infection that we hadn't
identified because you know if you if
you don't have source control of the
antibiotics are going to take longer to
bring down the microbial burden which
would you know or take the the
procalcitonin will take longer to
decline
thank you and are there studies that
show evidence of reduction of
antibiotics using causing antibiotics
use causing a reduction in the incident
of anti bio resistance
that's kind of yeah it has that much
more global we theoretically know that
using pro Cal or BC ID that as fast as
we could narrow therapy the less
exposure other microbial bugs in your
body have
to go resistant on you so Wes
antibiotics you would theoretically
think that resistance factors would not
enhance themselves as quickly
and thank you for that dr. burrito
thank you for a presentation and for
your time here today and I also want to
thank fear Mario for their underwriting
today's educational webcast and I want
to remind audience members that any
questions that weren't addressed today
the speaker will address some via email
using your registration information
thank you again and we would like to
hope to see all of you next time bye-bye